Good morning,
Board of Directors.
As all of you know,
from 2000 to 2007,
the US lost four million
acres in cultural land
to development.
It is really the size
of Massachusetts.
And although there are
federal policies targeted
to combat this loss
of farmland, they
are not nearly enough to
deal with this problem
we have here at home.
And so I'll speak
about three things.
Firstly, what I
intend to find out
on my upcoming trips to
EU, Japan, and Australia,
who I intend to find out
this information from.
Secondly, what opportunities
I see in these trips
for cross-contextual learning.
And thirdly, what
challenges I anticipate
translating this learning
to ideas and strategies
that are really useful
for us here in the US.
So firstly, in these
regions we intend
to focus on three critical
issues drawn from the problems
here at home.
We termed the three Ps--
place, policies, and people.
So firstly, this very strong
geographical notion of place
and a battle for it.
The US is losing its
finest land to development,
and we want to fight
out in these regions
how they view the trade-off
between development
and farmland protection,
or if it even exists
for them in the first place.
Secondly, we want to find out
what policies these regions
have to combat the development
of farmland into other uses
and that impact on performance,
and thirdly, the people.
We want to find out the
cultural institutions
the cultural mindsets to our
buttressing cases and policies,
essentially what the
stakeholders of these farming
communities are responding
to the policies that
are being developed.
So who do we intend to find
out this affirmation from?
We intend to look for
stakeholders' business
industry that are driving the
interaction between farmland
and development.
And they will inform us most
about the issues of place.
We also intend to talk to
the chairpersons and culture
committees in EU member states,
as well as officials in pockets
of every culture in
Japan, Australia,
to find out about their
experiences, that challenges,
and their successes when
dealing with farmland protection
policies.
We also plan to
look at the people
to whom these
effects of policies
are filtering down to the
members of the farming
community.
Who through their
individually unique stories,
as opposed to just
policy memos and big data
will inform us most
about issues of people.
We need these three
pieces together
to find out what was
intended, what is happening,
and what it really should be.
So the next idea I'll
would like to talk about
would be the why I want to
visit these three countries,
what opportunities there are.
Is it really necessary
and valuable endeavor?
And I would say yes because
these three regions are
similar enough to
the US to raise
the possibility of
opportunities for learning,
and yet different enough to
guarantee these opportunities
for learning.
So the US the EU,
Japan, Australia,
they are like the US next
industrialized nations.
If you look beyond the broad
similarities of wealth, power,
development levels, inference,
a whole host differences appear.
They are located in different
parts of the world--
the Western Hemisphere, Asia,
and the Southern Hemisphere--
there are different geographies,
histories, neighborhoods,
contexts, and ideologies.
And these differences drive
cross-contextual learning
for two reasons.
Firstly, they greatly
reduce the learning curve
for looking at the effects
of different policies
by providing a test bed with
exposed results as well.
So instead of sitting up with
all of us debating the merits
and demerits of increased
intervention in farming
policies, we need
only look at Japan--
highest-producing support
levels among OECD countries,
overly protective
subsidies that have
driven average annual
household income
levels 25% to 30% higher
than the national average
in Australia, the second
lowest producer support
levels of OECD
countries and where
a strong adherence to
market-oriented policies
has actually created a
different result from Japan.
And secondly, these
countries also
provide us with different
ideas that we might not
have considered before.
For example, the European
Union's common agriculture
policy contracts with
farmers for the provision
of ecological services, which is
alternative to the traditional
notion here in US where
farmland policy is essentially
meant to protect land
for productive purposes.
So essentially, exposure
to these new ideas
would provide us
a bigger toolkit
to develop more
robust strategies
for farmland protection
here in the US.
But with these
great opportunities
also come great challenges
in two forms, essentially--
differences in institutions
and differences in cultural.
So differences in institutions
like political systems, laws--
they essentially make policies
not all but irrelevant
to the United States
in a certain vein.
In European Union, they
have a greater acceptance
of regional-international
treaties and conventions.
And this has
implications for trying
to transplant policies across
the Atlantic and culture.
We cannot underestimate the
influx of culture, history,
and policies.
For example, after
all, in Japan,
the reason for the high levels
of producer support can be
traced back to the memories
shortage that occurred after
World War II, something that
cannot be said of the US.
So what may be
popular in my country
may be wildly
unpopular in another.
So what we intend
to do on our trip
is not to be transplanters of
these policies back to the US.
We intend to be translators
where we take the spirit
and not let letter
of these policies
and combine it with the our
understanding of the realities
here in the US to develop
a selection of ideas
that circumvent differences
in institutions and account
for differences in culture.
That said, even in the
US, the institutions
do change and cultures do
evolve [INAUDIBLE] at a much
lower rate.
And even within a country,
cultures do vary very widely.
So even ideas that
seem improbable for now
should not be discarded, but
kept for future reference
so whenever the time comes, we
are ready to implement them.
So in conclusion, my trips
will have great [INAUDIBLE]
opportunities, but also
affront with challenges,
but an appreciation that points
that differences in countries
are the drivers of learning,
and not similarities, and also
an appreciation that
policy-learning observations
are just a start to create
a translation effort
should allow us to reap the
full benefits of our trips.
Thank you for attending.